si tu avais le choix ayé c'est pour
faire l'amour mais entendu entre une
fille très très très jolie ou un mec
très laid tu choisirais quoi oh mais il
faut répondre oui ou non comme ça
maintenant répondre si jolie ou le mec
là oui peut-être qu'il est très
intelligent donc surprendre alors oui
parce que pas vraiment fille meilleur
mais ça déclarait d'ailleurs une fois je
me souviens on dit toujours que j'aime
les femmes et les fous et en fait je
fais les cas là à mon juge oui oui
maintenant je suis andré le mac les quoi
a priori oui
a priori le mac mais voilà définitif oui
alors imagine que ton mec t'es pas
touché pendant quinze jours
malte malgré des remarques persistante
en plus un tu as fait sentir que
effectivement pourrait s'intéresser un
peu à toi qu'est ce tu ferais tu
regardes ton carnet de téléphone on dit
en cherchant à un autre mec tu te jette
sur lui comme sable violemment un soir
dans la salle de bain pendant qu'il se
lave les dents dans sa robe de chambre
ou alors vous alors tu engages
détectives privés pour savoir avec qui
trompe pas être que tu auras faire dans
l'ordre
alors alors je jette sur lui d'abord
d'abord à fait d'accord mais comment ça
se passera pas je sais pas je leur fasse
une idée mais je suis reparti alors
qu'ils se lavent les dents par exemple
ben c'est à dire que oui je profiterais
déjà une main occupée loubic 1 sur le
bord du lavabo s'est discrètement bois
dans le miroir va commencer par le bas
imagine que j'en arrive à la troisième
solution parce que les deux premières
n'ont pas marché ce détective privé tu
te dis
ah oui qu'est-ce que je suis désolé vous
30 malades
qu'est-ce que tu ferais est ce que tu
lui couperait le sexe avec une
tronçonneuse à ces questions je suis pas
mal ça permet tu lui trancher le sexe et
qui vont ou non tu perces le coeur avec
une perceuse ça c'est déjà plus
puisqu'on sait pas où tu lui tire une
balle dans la nuque comme un chien mais
non me défonce enrager c'est le charme
et la fille puis à la limite je peux
peut-être veut faire pour une fois la
fille ah tu as revient sur ce que tu as
dit oui mais ça dépend des circonstances
marrant si tu te bats pourquoi penses à
j'essaye rapport tu sais que antenne 2
on n'est jamais censuré ce qu'est un
certain nombre de romains votre mission
est très bien tout ça mais il faut
arrêter de parler de nécrophilie à
l'antenne c'est un art eu que bon alors
on va parler de the office
ça ne l'ont pas dit très bien de ce gars
oui alors tu as le choix tu es obligé de
faire l'amour avec un animal obligé t'as
pas le choix car c'est comme ça est-ce
que tu avec un chien car la braderie
c'est joli et labrador annoncé le
labrador terme c'est un jeu bon parce
que tu préférais le labrador de giscard
labrador de mitterrand ni aux yeux de
réponse pas jamais le jamais la royale a
chanté pour le film sur l'arménie parce
que tellement de gens je sais pas si je
m'écoutais très gentil mais
on en a parlé ouais c'est ça s'est
arrêté là le rapport j'aurais pas dit
non il doit y avoir un truc et high tech
et en os qu ils ont plus pour le non et
puis à toute la soirée on peut très bien
participer c'est comme les éthiopiens
ils entendent jamais ce qu'on fait
pauvre et mal à imaginer mais l'enquêté
plein de thunes plein de thunes est ce
que tu préfères règles et en argent ou
prouve d'arméniens oppose éthiopien ça
c'est toujours une ramasser des
questions combien pas de réponse il faut
vraiment répondre la balle hors jeu les
pauvres arméniens qui sont sous les
décombres five ou encore qu'ils sont
vivants paraît-il où les pauvres
éthiopien cambrai n'a mangé je sais
c'est dur c'est à turin 3e moi j'en
envoie des tous les côtés a renoncé non
j'ai pas loin ça marche
les arméniens elle demande à son groupe
alors voilà une réponse
bah oui tu vois alors maintenant est ce
que tu préfères
mais c'est très très content que tu
préférais mourir comme john lennon parle
de mort de stars
est-ce que tu préfèrerais mourir comme
john lennon c'est à dire une balle dans
le monde
tu vois est ce que tu pourrais me faire
mourir comme janis joplin d'une overdose
ou comme le chanteur décide ici est mort
le pauvre s'étouffer dans son vomi
tu préfères la balle dans le grand bain
avis aux amateurs
était morte avant comme jeune lennon
mais t'as vu une émission sublime sur la
mort après bah oui à combien ma la façon
c'est un problème voilà alors est ce que
maintenant tu vas être réincarné bon tu
crois la réservation
voyons voyons 10 2 minutes
est-ce que tu préférais être réincarné
en fer à repasser
en face il y avait comme un inspirateur
ses obligés de réponse à ces papote
l'aide moi j'ai lu le bouquin il ya
vingt ans à l'ana non non ça c'est pas
possible on fait un vase et qui suit m'a
dit aspirateur machine à rêve que tout
simplement en faire un parfait tu
préfères tu en as oui oui parce que ça
fait des caresses aux gens
d'abord parce que ça fait tout et ça
peut être une vraie salle attendant les
comptes ils aspirent les conneries toute
la journée l'once il avait conneries 18
mois voilà donc le faire enfin passé l'a
imaginé deux minutes que tu prends
il faut toujours des magic c'est un jeu
arrive on imagine que tu prends qu'est
ce que tu reproches ray le plus ça du
tout non mais allons-y tout prenant des
exemples précis
est ce que tu lui reprocherait d'avoir
mis au monde finalement
rika zaraï ont été minimes cadets sousa
ah oui
marie france cuba dac est pas mal non
plus je te la concerne at est obligée là
alors mais là tout le monde l'aimait
tout être maman mais n'ont finalement
baissé des questions auxquelles tout le
monde réponde aux besoins répond alors
je répète marie france cuba da linda des
six là où rika zaraï qu'est ce que tu
reproches le plus au bon dieu d'avoir
mis sur peur mais non mais je ne
reproche pas ça se rapproche des trucs
bien pire cote a ensuite chassé grave je
trouve vraiment à l'étroit que je suis
jeune mais pas n'importe quoi je les ai
choisis extraire
voilà là mais c'est en mer dans des
temps d'assemblage sans mur surtout
quand tu as the pool et 3 tu ferais
peut-être un blue tu vois j'en sais rien
moi pas tu leurs proches les trois en
bloc en bas bowie temps cadors mais sur
des relais 3 bah voilà qu'est ce que tu
fais pas de jalouse la suite est pas
dieu alors imaginons maintenant que tu
survol l'angleterre en avion bon bien
sûr tu en conviendras que les deux
moteurs les moteurs sont en feu à
l'avion va tomber parce que tout l'avion
survole en angleterre pratique à les
deux motards ont fait la crise est là
bas c'est la musique pour moi qui
l'inventé ça est tous d'accord
donc c'est dans ce but vous êtes trois
lauréats
salma oui il ya deux parachutes
alors bon tambourin ah bon bah oui non
attentif et les deux autres trucs est
riche en sel n'ont pas mangé du riz
caire et plus près de man avant d'accord
donc tu donnes les parachutes à briquet
a tout eu
parachuté pas quand j'ai un truc un peu
tu fais bien ton business it le film et
parachutes aux gens quand des émissions
de télé qui tu veux et c'est bien tu
fais ton coup on fait plutôt drucker
quand même j'ai choisi le mec à 20h30
tous les samedis non mais non c'est pas
non non non non mais non c'est pas une
histoire de 20h30
c'était plutôt une histoire d'argent moi
je
non bon allez passons ou alors
maintenant dernière question ni
tradition si tu veux dans cette émission
c'est le vaisseau spatial tu dois partir
dans un vaisseau spatial sûrement parce
que c'est une histoire qui dure
d'émission en émission
il va partir et tu tu peux choisir sur
ces quatre ans vaisseau spatial c'est
pas de la rigolade et quatre ans avec la
même personne dans une coûteuse david
wright en apesanteur pendant quatre ans
avec la même personne
tarek après les muscles favori tu vas
voir d'ailleurs sur avait quitté à est
ce que tu préfères partir
attention on décolle avec france gall
lara catherine lara oui une véronique
sanson a fait outre ben oui c'est un jeu
et auquel monopoly c'est la rue de la
paix tu dois en choisir une des trois et
on est que toutes les deux pendant
quatre ans ma peugeot plonge tout soit
bénéfique à toutes les têtes que toutes
les deux à quelque chose de prendre a
déclaré l'expert parce que sans ça on a
choisi le laos et d'accueil ouardani
qu'elle prendra un petit maillot mais je
sais où enfin bon pointu couteau comme
ton couteau et un tu vois je m'étais ben
oui moi je crois que je suis pas
forcément complètement quand on est
vieux quelqu'un qui on voit un peu
d'attentes il a lancé alan bollard ans a
priori non véronique tendant donc
afrimar ah oui des gens d'expérience ils
sont marrants la roche dure qu elle
voulait à tout prix
ah ah